Hello. And welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host Rawkode, although sometimes known as
David Flanagan.
Today, we are continuing with Rawkode Live where
we take a look and get hands on
with
open source software
and the cloud native space to help make
your lives a little bit easier. And, you
know, for a second there, I forgot entirely
what I'm doing and why I'm here. However,
we're gonna be taking a look at a
really cool open source project today because it
solves a very difficult challenge. And I'm sure
if you're watching this, you've had to implement
identity and authentication at some point in your
career, probably many, many times.
Fortunately, that is a lot easier today.
To guide us on our journey of Zitadel,
I am joined by Florian.
Hello, Florian. How are you?
Hello. I'm doing great. Thank you.
Awesome.
Can
you just start and tell us a little
bit more about you?
For sure. I'm Florian. I'm CEO and and
cofounder of Zitadel.
And, I mean, there's many reasons why we
built Zitadel,
but one of which is we don't want
to give people
the pain that you need while building your
own authentication authorization solution because there is, like,
a lot of things to it. Right? So
it's not just two input fields and the
button because that's an absolute running deck. There
is way more depth to it. And, yeah,
we try to take a lot of that
pain away from people.
Yeah. I mean, surely, off end is as
simple as a form and submit and then
insert into user's username and password. You know?
We don't need to worry about that crazy
and hashing stuff or anything like that. Right?
Well, that's certainly off for a good start.
Yes. I mean, you can all already discuss
what hashing algorithms are correct and how to
use them properly and what salt and what
cost. And so, that's that's where the party
starts. And
that's not even without touching the new stuff.
Right? Pass keys that's around the corner or
many many already rely on and OTP and
what kind of OTP there is. And so
there is, like, so many flavors, and you
can do so many things wrong. And
I think it's specialization
in-depth that's kind of the the the brilliancy
behind the whole authentication and authorization and identity
topic in general,
and that's what we specialized in, basically.
Yeah. It's it's definitely
one of those areas of software development that
I think you're better just offloading that pain
to someone else like you. Right? Because
I know we joke, but it's just a
username, a password, save it at database rate.
You've got fine. That's that may be v
one, but it's definitely not something you ship
into production. That may have been cool in
1998,
but not so much anymore.
You also mentioned passkeys, which I think they're
very exciting. And but supporting them is a
bit of like the Wild West right now.
I'm hoping you're gonna show me something a
bit more nicer.
There's also hardware tokens. There's OTP. There's time
based OTP.
There's an OAuth too. So, you know, I
I still see people getting all of this
wrong today. You know when you go and
you sign in to a website and it's
like, okay. Log in with Google. Oh, shit.
I didn't use Google. Okay. Log in with
GitHub. They're both the same email address and
I end up with two different accounts and
it just all ends up confusing and I'm
just pulling my hair out going, this has
to be easier.
It Zitadel's gonna solve all of that for
me. Is that right?
For hopefully.
No pressure. Honestly no. No. I mean, at
least that's what you aspire to be. Right?
I mean, it it's like
I think sometimes of Citadel is like the
stripe of identity.
We try to keep the pumping work away
of people who just want to build their
applications.
And, I mean, as soon as you start
serving to enterprise customers, things can get really
weird. Like, then you need to have support
for SAML,
and SAML can be weird. There is not
even, a proper certification framework. And so there
the that's why I said there's so many
moving pieces in that stack
that
I and that's my certainly a biased opinion,
but I would rather use something that's predefined
and brings brings a lot of the stuff
Turkey with it rather than just building it
out in whatever framework I have lying around.
Even though I must say good things on
on
some of the frameworks out there. Some of
them are doing really well made stuff as
as long as you have, like, a tight
scope. As soon as it gets broader with
further integrations, it can get tedious.
Awesome.
Alright.
I'm gonna go off on a tangent first
and then come back. But I just wanted
to say,
I have taken a look at a lot
of tools in this space. And what I
love about Zitadel that's different from all the
other kind of awesome providers that I've seen
is that people might think identity is hard
and is enterprise y and it's no fun
and that it should just be, like, black
text on the way back around and boarding.
But the Zitadel branding and the aesthetic, I
just thought was absolutely top notch. I thought
that was breath of fresh air.
So
I just wanted to say, like, kudos. That
would I love that.
But let's get back. We could we could
we could talk about who who the name
is, the person on the team that does,
but whatever.
I wanna know
what your background is and how you got
into building
open source company around
identity.
Sure. I mean,
originally, I was a vehicle electronics engineer, so
I I built
yeah. I I honestly, that's kind of where
where we all started.
I I built and repaired electronics
in vehicles, especially
trucks and stuff and and first responder vehicles.
And so there you had
well, you should have a lot of security,
basically, but that well, there was not so
much security in there at that time. And
I thought, well, I don't stick to that
area of expertise for too long because you
get dirty hands. It's it's clam. You'll get
snow on your head if you try to
lay under a car. So, yeah, it was
a nice time, but I I switched carrier
pass after that. Basically, I I did some
military service and then went into the whole
we call call it IT at that point,
where I did a lot of system engineering,
basically. So
mainly the networking stuff like Cisco at that
point in time. I got some certifications rolling,
and then I I once again switched carrier
paths to the software side.
So, I mean, yeah, there's, like, a red
a red line through all of that because
can be programmed,
switches can be programmed to some extent depending
on the vendor.
And then I switched to to companies who
actually build software.
And after some more project driven companies, I
ended up in a company in Switzerland,
which built services for the public sector.
And there, I met the team that actually
built and operated identity systems for the public
government.
So first responders that needed to log in
somewhere to check a citizen's record and such
things. And during that time, the team and
I, we identified a lot of problems
around the existing solutions in the market. I
mean, like, the Keycloaks and Fortrox of zeros.
And we thought, why don't we just do
better? And since it was like the rise
of Kubernetes was really going at that point
in time, that was basically 2016
where, yeah, the hype just started,
we thought, why don't we build a cloud
native identity infrastructure
tool that is open source, that behaves well
on containerized
platforms,
and is more optimized for developers than the
past tools. Right? Because the past tools, in
our opinion, at least, were mainly focused towards
IT guys.
And we thought, well, we should have better
APIs, and so let's invest some time on
that end. Yeah. That's basically the origin story
of me and kind of Zitadel as well
to some extent.
Awesome.
I don't know why my camera keeps losing
focus, but hopefully it fixes itself.
Awesome.
I'm assuming whether it be in a cloud
native identity management solution, it's written in Go.
Is that a fair assumption?
Yes. It is.
Mean Yeah. I mean, that's that's that's a
good thing. I mean, it better if it
is Rust, but I'm not gonna split here.
It's right. But
we you know, Keycloak was amazing back in
the day. But running and operating Java, especially
in containers on Kubernetes, is is really, really
painful. And just having something that is
I'm gonna say modern, but I don't mean
that Keycloak is, like, integrated or anything, but,
you know, built on more modern technologies. And
again, I don't mean the Java. In fact,
you know what I do. Java is old
and crap. I don't like it. So
someone's gonna yell at me for that eventually,
but that's okay. Oh, they did already a
lot of yelling on our end too.
Actually,
I mean, to be honest, we took a
lot of inspiration of Keycloak,
but there were some concepts that were fundamentally
blow broken to to what we thought,
like that amount of realms you can run-in
parallel and and how you need to configure
and set up Keycloak to keep it scalable.
And, I mean, in the past, you couldn't
even do, like, proper zero downtime upgrades.
And so there was a lot of operational
hustle in in in Keycloak,
which we try to to solve as well
during the process.
And,
yeah, the language was just one means of
getting there.
It has some some nice benefits go, but
it
also has some drawbacks. Right? So I'm not
going to sugarcoat you too much there because
there is a drawback, and we'll come to
that as we we talk about how Zitadel
is built,
about about what what things we experienced during
that initial build phase.
Alright. Awesome. Well, let's cover just one more
thing, and then we'll get on to the
hands on component, and we'll actually show people
how to get started.
Zitadel,
we said open source more than once now,
but I I I wanna clarify. Is Zitadel
you are a SaaS based company, so you
do offer to manage all of this for
people, and they can sign up for Zitadel
cloud and get started without installing or running
anything. But is it open source? Is it
open core? What is your business model, and
how do you work with open source community?
We we think
the
everything related to authentication and authorization
and audit capabilities and getting your data out
of an identity system needs to be open.
And
to the point in time, we run the
same code in our cloud service. Our paying
customers run the same code as the open
source version that you can fetch from GitHub.
So right now, everything is an Apache two
license and fully open source. And I can
tell where we will draw a line down
the future will be things like analytics and
and and reporting
stuff because that's where we think we can
provide value add stuff for for paying customers,
basically. Because there is a lot of interesting
data buried in identity.
You basically get the high quality data pinned
to a user, and you can tell what
happened with a user in the past, where
he locked in from, what what what user
agent he had, and all such things.
And that can be used in a positive
way for our customers. And and I can
tell you what what's in there because that's
a a huge bag of interesting features.
But right now,
the the as is state is really like
is full blown open source
deployed
wherever you want, however you want. And if
you're big enough and interested in a support
contract, please call us up. There is a
contact section on our website.
Or if you don't want to hustle off
of operating Zitadel,
well, use our cloud service. There is even
a free tier
that you can use to to get basically
rolling with your project.
Awesome. Alright.
One last thing. I know I keep saying
that, but I love that you give that
history. Right? You went from a physical engineer,
you went, no. Fuck that. I like it.
To doing
government jobs. Oh, no. Wait. Before that, you
did networking. Right? So it's Cisco and CCNA
and you went, no. Fuck that. CCNA went
to the government, and then you did identity.
And then you went, oh, identity in SAML.
That's my jam. I mean, you know, you're
a certain type of crazy.
But But
but in all honesty, XML is not exactly
my favorite choice.
Somebody needs to do it. Right?
Alright. Well, let's dive into the crazy rabbit
hole and take a look at Zitadel.
So I'm gonna pop my screen up. We're
still here. Amazing. This is like I said,
the aesthetics on this are just very nice
and the logos is lovely too. It's not
important to the software, but it always makes
me smile when I find a good really
good landing page.
Thank you.
And it's also pass along the celebrations there.
Yeah. I'll go to pricing first. So, yeah,
here is that free tier. So, you know,
if you like what you see today, definitely
go to .com.
Jump in. You get a free instance
with
all the security features, and it can have
up to 100 daily active users, which is
probably adequate for most of but it's adequate
for all my projects times 10 the activity.
So that's pretty good.
Let's go to documentation,
and we're gonna work on the getting started
guide for today.
So I haven't looked at this. I always
like to come into it with a fresh
set of eyes. So we're gonna be I
have no I have no idea what we're
gonna be working through, but I'm assuming we're
gonna have some sort of random website that
we can spin up where we could integrate
Zitadel and get some sort of authentication system
up and running all in Yep. Less than
six or seven hours. Right?
For sure. I mean, I would I would
say we start with a self hosted Zitadel.
Right? Because the the core message here is
kind of yeah. Just use the open source
project.
And you can simply start it by going
on the top corner. There is navigation with
self hosting.
Yes. Perfect. And then I I would advise
we use Docker Compose because it's basically the
easiest to get started with.
And
the point blank, you can download that file
and Docker Compose up the whole thing, and
you should be ready with Zitadel that
runs a CockroachDB in this case. We support
CockroachDB and Postgres. It's a matter of choice,
actually, or what you prefer.
For the sake of simplicity, we use your
Cockroach, usually.
I I I default to Postgres for everything
because I've got twenty years of operating it,
and it's and I know how to manage
it.
Cockroach is always one of those things. I'm
like, it's really cool.
I know it's got influence from Spanner, from
Google, which means it's very, very cool,
but I just haven't dived into it enough
to really take on the operational responsibility
yet. So Yeah. I mean, we're we'll just
work on an article where we compare Postgres
and Cockroach and some learnings from our operational
side, operating the cloud service.
And, yeah, that should come, yeah, I guess,
in the next few weeks from our end
to explain more in-depth on when to choose
what because, basically, both have their strong suits
and weak suits. Right?
Yeah.
Alright. So we do have a dark horse
pose. I'm already happy because it's under 40
lines. A million investors key cloak, I would
be 400.
So
let's see.
I will remove your restart because that's
that's wild.
Go away. Go.
Put the custom away.
I also
just I don't need to do this, but
I'm just doing it because if I were
doing it if I were doing this on
my own and I didn't have people watching,
I would be like, why do people do
the less syntax for environment? Because it loses
the the syntax highlighting.
I don't know why it's like, why would
you do this? Anyway I need to ask
my colleague why he did this actually.
That's a good question.
Yeah. That's that's all great. We need a
32 character string. It's just the master key.
That's fine. We've got Zitadel network and Yeah.
Everything down there. So we're using nice 3.8
stuff. We've got service healthy. This this is
a nice Dockerfile except for your environment stuff.
So
I would say, p o's welcome since we're
open source.
I I think I've also met that pull
request.
And I'll have, like, a forward paragraph description
of why we should do it this way
for a two lane change, but still. Yeah.
So we'll let cockroach d p get healthy.
Yeah. And then That should take out Yeah.
Ten seconds. Ten ish seconds, Zitadel will do,
like, the migrations here.
And, yeah, as soon as you should see
the Zitadel thingy, it's basically ready to run.
So you can click the the URL there,
and it should bring you to the management
UI.
At least that's what it should do.
Perfect.
And if you go back to the documentations
page, there is the default user
somewhere exactly.
There will be Aviso that one point in
time, but you can pass the configuration
to to predefine that stuff if you want.
Yeah. So
I'm disappointed that your default password is password
one exclamation mark and and not a hundred
twenty two.
I was very disappointed that in the last
two weeks,
bash dot org is down forever. I don't
know if you ever used to read bash.org,
but I I grew up with bash.org.
I I I did from time to time.
Yeah. You can skip on the left lower
left if you don't wanna set a multi
factor off.
I mean, for the sake of you can
you can't just you can skip it away
if you want. Right. Okay. We'll we'll do
it. And then we need we certainly force
you to change the password. What kind of
security product would we be if we don't?
It's like
I have too many passwords stored on this
local host and it's all I mean, they're
the market so quick.
Classic.
Oh. I guess you you violated something.
What was it?
Perfect. Should work.
So that actually password is invalid usually means
the original password is invalid.
Yeah. I probably typed that wrong.
Perfect. Now it should
basically give you a spin.
Perfect.
Off you go. Zitadel is running, basically.
I mean, there is a lot of things
you need to consider going to production. Right?
But from from
getting started experience,
that's as as quick as Zitadel can be
operationalized
locally.
Alright. Well, thanks for watching, everyone. We'll see
you next week.
Done.
I I do like I mean, obviously, I'm
not gonna run a docker compose file for
any sort of production deploy. But again, this
is a Go application. So it's probably even
easier to get it running. And then it's
just about making sure that that
database is backed up and you've got your
store processes, all that operational stuff. But I
love the simplicity of getting that started. And
that master key, I'm curious.
We passed in on the CLI. Can that
read from, like, cloud KMS systems?
I mean, what are my other options to
keep that secure?
I mean, you can pass it in usually,
we recommend passing it in as RQ because
all the other things are passed as environments,
and so it's kind of easier to get
the separation of concern going.
Honestly, it's just an additional layer of security
because some passwords in the database
the password, but some secrets in the database
are encrypted in an asymmetrical
way, like with a s in that case.
And it's just an additional safeguard if your
database leaks. Somehow, you you do not leak
out all the guts of of your Citadel.
Right? So Okay. It's just more that because
one one example that we use
symmetric cryptography tool is for the private keys
that we use to to sign jobs tokens,
for example,
or the certificates for SAML and stuff. Mhmm.
That's where what it mainly does right there.
Okay.
Alright.
The onboarding process wants me to create a
project, register my app, and log in to
my app. So let's crack on.
We'll call this the Rawkode Academy.
I have a project, roots research ID,
applications,
rules,
grants. Alright. All that fun off stuff.
Yeah. Yeah. We can talk in a minute
about all the the underlying concepts there. I
would I would advise we quickly
run, like, an OAuth proxy, for example,
and
that can be used as an example application,
or we can use a Vue application,
or we can use a Grafana or whatever
is to your liking. I I usually tend
to use it for an an external tool
like OAuth Proxy because it's just the binary
on the config file and does a great
job for showing people how how they can
work.
Yeah.
Well, I'm assuming we have to create an
application first. Is that correct?
No? Yeah. That means you need to know
what application. When we settle for for an
OAuth proxy, yeah, go away and and create
create a new application right there. There is
a wizard.
We we try to give people,
like, a little bit of guidance
because if you click on new there,
you see, like, multiple things there. Right? It's
like web application, native applications, user agent, APIs,
and SAML.
The reason being, like, web application is your
classic web application with a server rendered
engine.
Native is when you're using mobile apps or
desktop apps, and user agent is basically the
good old single page application.
The API is kind of special because, yeah,
it's for for back end systems. Like, you
get the token, you want to do something
with it. But in this case, we stick
to web application that works perfectly. Want to
do SAML?
Oh, no. I don't.
I even though it's it's it's a thing.
Yes.
But I if you could skip it for
today, you know, I I would advise doing
that. Otherwise, we'll we'll be around midnight to
to to do the metadata exchange.
In
this case, let's pick code here
that works great for the the OAuth proxy.
I'm just I I can explain the differences
if you're interested, but let's let's keep it
tidy for the moment being and dive after
that into it again.
Okay.
Alright.
Yeah. Just continue here. You because we can
we can change that afterwards. It's fine.
Alright. So
So you get two values like there. You
should copy them, especially the client secret. Otherwise,
you can regenerate it.
Perfect. And
then let's go to trust the OAuth proxy.
You should find it on on Google by
quickly
because we combine can combine multiple things here.
Right? Yeah. Perfect. That's the thing. There is
a download guide on the website on the
yeah. On the on the
yes? Nope. Nope. Not oh, yeah. Okay. No.
It works perfect. You can download the prebuilt
binary or use Go, whatever suits your taste
here.
I often use the the prebuilt binary quickly.
I wonder if it's in package x,
which I I always check everything now. Is
it off to a proxy or off proxy?
It is. That's
a good question. I have never checked it.
I could think there is no. No. I
like it. I'm I've I've become like,
I used to use Knicks for all my
local development environments, and it's just I just
got so frustrated having to write Knicks myself.
And then I discovered Package X, which is
like a project from the person that originally
built homebrew.
It's like reimagined homebrew, and it's it's really
nice. I like the way it works.
So Sure.
Alright. We have a proxy.
Perfect. So we have a planer at least.
Yeah. If you go back to their page
and the OAuth proxy page,
there is an OAuth provider configuration. Yes. Go
go ahead with this one, and then let's
select the
let's use Okta's.
So there is oh, somewhere there is an
Okta configuration, isn't it? Oh, there's OpenID Connect.
Let's go with OpenID Connect. That's fine.
Let's scroll down a little bit because we're
gonna use a config file. No. No. Go
to scroll a little bit downwards.
Yeah. Let's let's copy the this thing here.
That's perfect right there. Yes.
Because that's basically applicable to Zitadel as well.
Perfect.
So now let's call the the redirect URL
there.
Let's do HTTPS,
And and I think in their guides, they
use
I mean, if you can you quickly go
back to the
your example? And a little bit upwards to
the OpenEye Connect example.
Yeah. Let's let's use the redirect URL there
because that's the default port for Rawkode proxy,
if I remember correctly.
Perfect. You missed an h, but no worries.
And on the OIDC issue, you can use
HTTP
local host in our case because we don't
use a DEX. We use Zitadel.
But that's basically
exactly local host eighty eighty.
Yes. That should be fine.
And then upstreams, let's use HTTP bin. That's
basically where the OAuth proxy will send traffic
as soon as it authenticated
us.
And email domains, you can use citadel.
Local host.
Perfect.
And client ID, client secret, you just copied
right before we switch to here.
Perfect. And then I think the the cookie
secret needs some c's more. That should be
16 bits, so just throw in, like, 11
c's
or whatever.
Yeah.
Perfect.
That's basically it.
Now the redirect URL
on on row two, that's that thing you
should copy.
Perfect. And then let's switch to Zitadel.
And you have the redirect settings.
Exactly. Throw it in there. Press enter.
I I you need to to press the
plus sign or press enter. I know. UX
and bad. The development mode needs to be
activated, and there is a reason for it.
The in in in yeah. The specification
basically demands to use HTTPS,
and we
don't want people to to fire away their
production into whatever weird state they can they
can get it, and that's why we have,
like, a development mode. So you need to
turn it on to get an unsafe configuration
rolling in Zitadel. But after that, you are
fine to do whatever you want to do.
It's just an additional safeguard for people.
Yeah. Then let's save it.
Perfect. No changes. So it should be already
saved. Right?
Yeah.
Cool. Yeah. So let's
start there at the OAuth proxy and see
how it goes. That's basically
it should be, like, OAuth proxy and then
minus minus for configure, I guess, or something
like that.
Call that. Oh, no. I called it Rawkode.
Oh,
could see I need some more bytes. Yeah.
It's a classic.
Whatever you throw in there, just two bites
and off you go.
Perfect.
So, yeah, let's browse to local host
4178,
I guess, off the top of my head.
I guess. Right.
Or is it not? Oh, I just quickly
need to check the configuration.
It's not written here. That's kinda bad. But
418. Yeah. Alright. Yeah.
Wrong window. There we go.
418.
Perfect. Forbidden. So if you click sign in
here,
we should do the good old OpenID round
trip, and off you go. You have authenticated
with yourself with Zitadel.
Right. Right?
That's all it took.
So what OAuth Proxy basically does here is
it allows traffic only through
when you have successfully authenticated
with Zitadel. And if you go for your
terminal
in that case,
You should basically see here that somewhere your
user should be written out.
Where is it? Is it I I it's
in the lower third.
There is, like, authenticated view of session,
email, Zitadel, yada yada yada. You see that.
Right? Yeah. Okay. I wanna I just wanna
make sure I understood all this. Okay? So
because that I mean, obviously, that all worked
rather fast.
So Yep. I mean, what we What we're
that's 4188.
What we did there, right, is
okay. I don't need to sign out. It's
just temporary
authentication.
Yep. What I want to do is log
out of Zitadel
Yep. And click sign in here.
Okay. Cool. So what we've what we did
was we set up Zitadel as an OAuth
two provider.
It's not going to other external subparity provider
as
the source of authentication.
In which case, it was using my account
here, which is currently signed out, where I
can log back in, and it's gonna give
me back a token, and I'm now authenticated
again. Okay. Yes.
And I mean That was painless.
Right? And you can do, like, many flavors
of it. There is, like
whatever I mean, we can plug in a
view app. We can plug in a Symphony
app.
There is multiple ways of of attaching applications
to Zitadel. And that's just for for the
sake of simplicity.
Yeah. Many
prebuilt tools use, like, OpenID Connect or OAuth.
I mean, that's kind of an overlapping term.
There is a a proper
differentiation between the two, but for the lack
of better management, let's keep it like federated
authentication.
And and
those tools just rely on Zitadel on doing
the authentication
piece. Right? They get basically a code back,
and with that code, they go to Zitadel
and get back a token, oftentimes an ID
token, an access token,
which they can use then if they need
it to communicate with another service or in
that case, the proxy says, well,
you are authenticated,
mate. I I let you through and off
you go.
That's the that's the piece in in how
fast it can go. It works also with
Grafana. They have an OAuth provider. It works
with GitLab.
It works with many, many different systems. And,
also, it works with language frameworks like Angular,
Next, and and and multiple others. But that's
not all Zitadel can bring to the table.
And because that's just one protocol here. Right?
Mhmm. With Zitadel, you can even build your
own login UI, like the the thing you
saw with the the the username password thing.
You can build that on your own if
you'd like to. There is an API for
that, And and we can even, like, deploy
a quick demo later on on on Versal
or something like that where you can self
host the login page as well.
But that's
the the appeal of Zitadel, basically. So
now we can talk details, I guess,
or dive in any direction you want or
we want to dive into.
Yeah. I mean, there's a different a few
different avenues we can do down here. Right?
I think
what I love is that in under thirty
minutes,
we've got an OAuth provider running, doing identity
management for an organization,
a team, a product, whatever you want.
Yeah.
And I have successfully logged in right off
the bat. So we already seen the setup
process. We created a project. You know, we
we can see that we configure the applications
and how those all communicate.
Let's
talk about some of those security considerations that
also come from you know, if I'm gonna
roll my own identity solution,
auditability is gonna be really important. So what
is Zitadel given me
to help me understand how my users are
consuming and working with the projects that I
create?
Well, that's where the funny piece of Zitadel
comes into play. It's we built Zitadel in
a kind of unique way for the identity
industries.
For all those who are interested in a
topic, it's basically based on event sourcing and
and CQRS.
So we truly separated the the writing side
of the system from the reading side. And
there is a lot of material on on
reading up
all those those two patterns.
But the unique reason we chose basically to
use event sourcing as a concept is that
we have a perfect audit trail, so to
say. We know what happened in the past.
And we can quickly visualize that if you
go on the right top corner of Zitadel,
there is an instance button,
and that's basically the root level of Zitadel
because it it is has multitenant.
And in in in the top navigation, we
have events.
And if we could go there
yeah. The event thingy. And that's basically all
the things that happened in Zitadel so far.
And you can filter them through different things,
and and
you can also look at the payload on
the on the right side. You can expand
the events.
Yep. I mean, UI wise, it's not super,
but
somebody needs to improve the UI.
Thing is, you can also get those information
out through
an REST API or a gRPC API in
our case.
And that means you can filter out whatever
your users did on whatever they did on
on whatever resource.
So it gives you a lot of insights
what what happens in your system. So you
can pull out each operation that Zitadel did
and or a long time. You you see,
like, accept languages and whatnot. So
do, I guess, to build whatever you wanna
build up on top on that. That's kind
of the idea. Let's give our users back
their data. Right?
And that's
just the the guts of Zitadel. It's basically
a glorified SQL table in a Postgres. Right?
It's just an events table where we write
an append only log, and, yeah, that's what's
what's got thrown out there. Usually, you will
have more than, like,
so little events. But
okay.
You can also configure a a password
Yeah. Just try to local policy.
Just there's some interesting stuff. So let's go
back to that and to and by the
way, the minute you said CQRS and event
sourcing, I was sold. I'm a huge advocate
of event sourcing. I think it's such a
powerful way to build software. So Yes. Go
to events again because that's that's more technical
errors. Here, you have, like, the the
the check password check failures. Right. There it
is. And if you expand the event, you
see some additional metadata.
Yeah. But the IP address, user agent, stuff
like that. Okay. Exactly. And the funny thing
being all about we envision of Zitadel and
the reason why we chose event sourcing also
is we can train
machine learning models that basically can identify
threats in the past. And that's the funny
thing with event sourcing. Right? You can train
models,
and then we can give them to our
customers.
And with their models, we can fortify
our our our models and see whether they
had breaches down the road or whether they
had, like, signals that might have a weird
feeling to them.
And and and that basically is good for
security operations and SOC centers in general.
But that that as I said, that's the
reason why we chose to keep everything open
source in regard of the identity infrastructure piece
and only
keep the analytics piece to ourselves because that's
the thing where where you can produce additional
value for for paying customers.
That's basically the story right there.
Besides,
what Zitadel is optimized to is definitely, like,
b to b stuff
where you have multi tenants involved.
And and I'm certainly I think we should
talk about that in a in a minute
or so because that that's the reason why
Zitadel is built in a way it is
built currently and from a data architecture
standpoint.
Oh, yeah. If you wanna go bonkers on
the keyboard layout.
Yeah.
I'm here for this. I'm so happy.
That's by the way, it's a a name
you'll agree,
what you're looking at. It it it uses
the same APIs as everything.
So we don't we we do, like, eat
your own dog food thingy because we think
it's it's worth using our own APIs. That's
why we we even have an ongoing effort
to to create newer APIs, like a version
two APIs that have an improved
developer experience,
basically.
Yeah. You can customize your eyes and everything.
I'll stop the second randomly.
We do have a question in the chat,
which we'll get to in just a second.
So
alright. We have Zitadel.
Things are working. I'm clicking on things. The
keyboard driven thing is a nice little cherry
there just to sweeten the deal that I'm
very happy about. But the question is
oh, it's a bit small. Let me
can we dive into this a little bit
more with regarding
organization
project grants and identity
brokering?
Sure.
I mean, that's the the beef and butter
work of Zitadel, basically. Because
from a data architecture standpoint and you can
go to our docs. I guess we have
a
graph for that. So if you quickly go
go to our documentation,
and then
let's go to documentation
on in in the top menu,
and then concepts on the left side.
Yes. And then there is let's use instances
for the first. Yes. Perfect.
So
even though the graph is not especially the
nicest one in the world, it it we
try to show what what's going on in
Zitadel. And
so
one Zitadel binary
can have multiple Zitadel instances.
So you can run multiple virtual
identity systems in parallel. That's basically how we
operate our cloud service, and some of our
customers operate their systems.
And each Zitadel instance within itself is an
isolated system.
It has its own
IDs in the database, and and and it
basically acts as the thing you use as
customer
most of the time.
And within an instance, there is a concept
of organizations.
You can think of them like in an
LDAP directory organizational
units.
They are comparable
to realms in a Keycloak. It's not exactly
the same because with Zitadel, the intent was,
let's create one identity system that is the
trust anchor. So you basically plug in your
application into Zitadel. You trust Zitadel to do
the job properly,
and then you configure
your your application
inside
an organization.
Like, if I'm if if I'm creating
a cloud service, for example, I create an
organization for my own company. In our case,
we have an organization called Zitadel in our
cloud service.
And therein,
we have our applications
or all the things that's tied together
And to to to have multiple applications
combined together,
we have what's
called a project. So that's basically the hierarchy.
It's instance,
organization,
and and project.
And the users always belong to an organization.
So a organization typically
is is a vessel for either b two
c users. So you can create an organization
where you throw in all your customers, consumers,
and then you can create organizations
for each business customer or for each team.
So that's more whatever your data model basically
is.
And and that helps you separating
different configurations
from each other. So, for example,
if you have a b to b scenario,
well, customer a might want to use Azure
AD to log in, so he can configure
Azure AD in in his organization.
And customer b wants to use
Okta, so he can configure Okta in his
organization. And it's clear, okay, customer a uses
Azure AD, customer b uses Okta,
and Zitadel knows through the username to which
organization the user belongs and can forward accordingly,
which basically turns into what what's called identity
brokering
because we take the identity of the external
system,
generate the user object in Zitadel, and attach
the external identity to it, and give then
to the application that trust Zitadel
an ID that was generated by Zitadel. And
we do that because we want to, a,
retain the audit trail. We wanna assign permissions
to to to that user.
And, also,
maybe there is a scenario where
the same user has multiple identity sources. Right?
You already said in the beginning, like, okay.
You might have a GitHub and a GitLab
account. Maybe you want to attach both external
identities to the same identity in Zitadel. That's
basically the concept
of identity brokering.
So Okay. Can I just make sure I
understand this Yeah? Correctly?
So, you know, I'm a human, which means
I have an identity. Right? I am me.
And I go sign up first. Let's call
it amazing service a,
and I use my GitHub authentication, and I
have an account, and I got access to
whatever resources this company gives me. Right? But
then my employer then signs a b two
b deal with them,
and they want me to log in with
my Google account. I'm still the same person.
Right? I'm not I've not been split in
two.
Yep. What we're what you said there is
me as a person, I could log in
with my GitHub, attach my corporate identity. I'd
be part of this organization, but still part
of the b two c organization,
but my authorization
would be extended to the extra resources provided
by my org other organization. Is that is
that correct?
That's feasible. It's not the default what we
recommend
because it's, like, it's it's hard for your
company to manage stuff that way.
In in Zitadel's world, it's actually totally feasible
because
that's where the concept of grants come in.
Grants is basically a concept of
an an an application provider
can give a user permission to do something,
or an application provider can give an organization
the right to do something, and in turn,
they can assign the permission to their users.
Right? So it's either direct to a user
or indirect through an organization.
And that's often
what happens in the b to b scenario.
It's basically, okay. I, as company, have a
contract with GitHub, for example,
and I want on my own to be
able to give my users
admin rights or viewer rights or billing administrator
or whatnot
to do because that's what I want to
do. Right? I own the organization, Zitadel, on
GitHub. And that concept is basically what we
call brands in different flavors.
Okay.
So everything we've talked about so far is
on the Us end
side of the
I call it spectrum. Right? But I I
I do see grant rules and authorizations.
Does Zitadel offer off zed as well as
off end? And how does we haven't seen
that yet. So how does that work?
Yeah. We try to to keep it lean
at the moment there, and which basically means,
yeah, on the authorization space, we provide role
based access control
and attribute ace access
attribute attribute
based access control. That's the two things we
provide right now. And is that just done
through claims within the GWT that you you
provide?
That's one way of doing it. Yes. I
mean, you can throw it into a claim
in a token.
You can throw it in a sample assertion.
You can throw it into to the user
info, introspection response from Zitadel. So there's multiple
ways tackling it.
But generally speaking, yes, you're correct there.
Alright. Nice. Yeah. I think this
concept space is is a good way to
understand
the vocabulary that people would probably need to
bring on board and understand as they Yeah.
Boards of the data there. You know? And
so these organizations,
projects, applications, grants, and so forth like this.
It seems like a pretty good place where
people should spend a little bit of time
to be familiar before they start shipping this
into production.
Yeah. That's we usually recommend people at least
getting some some
briefer idea on instances, organizations, and projects because
that's the meet main concepts if you're dealing
with user management and authentication.
As soon as you're diving into the authorization
space, you should look at the grant
grant stuff, like, for
the granted projects piece there because that's
a delegated
scenario
where
for example, if you're going back to the
GitHub example, I, as GitHub,
gives Zitadel the opportunity
to self manage who is administrator.
Right? And so GitHub
delegates
the administrator role to the organization Zitadel, and
the organization Zitadel can give that role to
somebody within Zitadel or even outside of Zitadel.
So that's the the delegation model. And so
that's mostly applicable to b to b scenarios
because I, as Wendell says something to another
business, and I don't really care whom of
their crew is doing what besides that I
wanna have it auditable.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright. I'm
I'm gonna ask a question, and it's either
gonna be a really good question. You're gonna
have an amazing answer or you're gonna hate
me. I don't know which way it's gonna
go. Alright? But but so far,
everything we did, we clicked around.
Yep. And while it's got an amazing set
of keyboard shortcuts, which I could explore for
days,
I am a as code
kind of person.
Yeah. What are my options? Do we have
the ability to
commit
my organizations,
my projects, stuff like that, at least some
of it to get
or use SDKs?
Like, is there any way for me automate
like, let's assume
my Zitadel's compromised. I need to rebuild it.
No. That could just be a database resource,
but maybe I wanna start for I don't
know. Like, how how do I do this
in a way that's reproducible? Can I?
Sure. If you quickly go to our documentation
page, there is, like on on the top,
there is APIs
because that's basically the starting point. There is
a lot of APIs in Zitadel.
And with without going into too much detail
right now, because I could talk for hours
about APIs,
It it always boils down to Zitadel providing
APIs either standard based, like OpenID Connect or
sample stuff. That's the baseline stuff.
And then we have APIs to change objects
in Zitadel, like create users, delete users, create
applications, everything. And,
for example, if you go to the left
hand side and
see user life cycle, for example, let's let's
pick that one, and then you go for
the user service.
Yeah. That's you can look at the create
user, for example.
Yeah. That's basically
resource based API where you can create users.
Right?
From there on out, you have multiple options.
There is, for example, a Terraform provider
people use to manage resources in Zitadel. You
can find that on GitHub or on the
Terraform registry.
Exactly.
Which
can help you configure,
like, organizations and such things. It can also
create users. It's not not what we usually
recommend doing because reconciling users is kinda bad
if the user changes thing and so back
and so forth. But you can use
Terraform if that's the the the poison of
your choice. Right? You can use Pulumi. There
is even a Pulumi provider built on top
of the Terraform provider,
or we already have some SDKs for certain
languages, for example, for Go or for .net
to also do the same. Right? So that's
why I said it's multiple angles
tackling the same problem. So it kind of
depends on your use case,
what what fits your needs there.
Yeah. I'm good with a terra firm provider.
You should have started with that. Come on.
Like, like, I was expected to open this
resources list and see, like, you know, you
you're like, oh, yeah. We we kinda have
this TerraForm provider and a few people use
it. I said, oh, there's gonna be, like,
two resources. And then, like, everything is just
sat there.
Yeah. It's it's it's it's not everything, but
it's we try to keep it really, like,
comprehensive,
so to say.
Because we have enterprise customers who also use
Terraform, and they're quite happy because they can
create new applications and projects across environments,
for example, within their Zitadel. Right? They can
just copy the environments and off they go.
I mean, I would probably just raise some
Rust. I mean, this API seems to be
pretty comprehensive as well. So, you know, generate
That's good. SDK and a way I go,
I think I'd be quite happy. Actually,
there is a
all our APIs
based on on on gRPC.
And if you go to our repository,
I can quickly guide you through it. So
that's you've got protobufs just hanging around waiting
for me as well then. Okay. Exactly.
It's it's that it's that simple. Like, close
to everything has a has a proto with
us.
So if you go for Zitadel, the repository,
and then it's a proto.
Yes. And then you see there is Oh,
buff. Very easy. Yes. So you can generate
whatever you is your poison right there. And
yeah.
That's that's what you You've got the right
answer to everything today. I'm just smiling my
entire way through this because,
I mean, I've I've I've got a buff
file. I I have I mean, it's got
an instant gRPC SDK ready to go, and
that works beautifully with Rust angle. So, I
mean, I'm sitting pretty happy with that.
We we use it even for, like, the
the management console you you clicked around. The
the the Angular code there as well uses
gRPC web to to to
change resources.
And so we provide REST services, gRPC web,
and gRPC.
But, honestly, it's just a transformation of the
gRPC model to the other languages to the
other API
frameworks.
And and as said, there is a v
one API that that was more use case
oriented.
If you go for the Zitadel folder, you
can see the difference there.
Yes. That's that's the thing. And there you
see, like, that's the old APIs on the
top folder, so semantically not super nice. But
the new APIs with the v two beta
flag, for example,
if we go for the yeah. Let's take
the session API or whatnot. And then there
is a session proto, and everything is nice
and tidy, and you have, like, the descriptor
fields for the open API specification as well.
And so it's it's up to pick your
poison, really, like, what suits you best. That's
why we were kind of hesitant in the
past to create too many SDKs because we
thought people, hey. There is your buff generates.
Do whatever you do. Yeah. Everything
is already there. Right?
Yeah. Definitely.
Buffs are pretty solid way to go. I
mean, gRPC in general is is, like, if
you go down that path and everyone can
generate their clients, fine. But Buff does make
it just that little bit easier to consume.
Oh, yeah. In the past, it was kind
of painful.
We've grown to see directly and so.
Awesome.
Alright. We do have a question on the
chat, so we should pop over to that
instead of me just clicking around helplessly having
fun with them.
Alright.
So
can there be multiple organizations that use brokering?
For example, GitHub wondering about the discovery and
creating the user upfront.
Not sure I understand that question. Do you?
I try to to I mean, I think
I know where it points out. Yes. And
I'm
just implying here, but, yes, multiple
organizations in Zitadel can use GitHub.
Though we should not we do not really
comment recommend that they use the same configuration.
In GitHub, anyway, you can't can only have,
like, one redirect URL.
So at least that was in the past
like that.
But you can have multiple GitHub
IDPs
in in in in Zitadel.
The brokering piece happens on an instance level.
So there is multiple ways of triggering
what we call domain discovery.
That's basically where Citadel tries to figure out
on which organization a user belongs to. Ah.
And
we have if you go to the documentation
layer,
basically, on the top left documentation again,
there is
where
was it? Just
use the search quickly.
Domain discovery or discovery should should bring you
up. Yeah. Domain discovery. Perfect.
Because there is multiple
ways Zitadel can discover where the user belongs
to.
First and foremost, we pass the username and
figure out where the user belongs to because
the username needs to be unique globally.
And the same applies to if there is
a identity
provider configured for the whole instance, like, for
everybody, well, then in that case, we can
figure it out.
If that's not applicable,
we can pause, for example, the user's email
address and tell, okay. If the email address
ends with at zitadel dot com, well, that
belongs to the organization from Citadel,
and then we can prompt the user, hey.
This is your organization.
Please use whatever is configured on that organization.
That can be automatically
redirecting
to GitHub. It can be
prompting the use of our passkey. It can
be
leaving the user a selection of things like
username,
password,
and or
GitHub. So there is multiple permutations of it,
but that's basically the way Zitadel tries to
figure out where the user belongs to.
And to make sure everything is unique in
Zitadel, each user automatically
gets an internal username assigned.
And if you quickly go for Zitadel's UI,
I can show you how that looks like.
So we have, like, the the Zitadel organization
here. That's the first organization that you create.
And you you
the yes. Exactly. You can you can.
Yes. The user is perfect. Click just click
on the user quickly here,
and you see on the top right, there
is login methods.
So it's basically username,
Zitadel minus admin, that's the username,
at Zitadel dot localhost. That means the organization
is called Zitadel,
and your
Zitadel
the whole thing is called localhost
right now.
And that's the semantics on how we can
figure it out easily because we know, okay,
Zitadel admin, well, there can only be one
in at Zitadel in dot local host. So
that that that's where it trickles down.
You can define those those domains on your
own. It's just we we pre regenerate
something for you already.
Oh, I'm so sorry. Answers the question. Yeah.
I I mean, I I hope I answered
the question. I'm not entirely sure. I'm just
clicking about now, but yeah. Yeah.
You found the peso list.
Well, yeah.
Is there you you mentioned pass keys at
the start, and I know it's very early
in the pass key adoption. Does Zitadel support
pass keys as a
it does? Go for, yeah, password and security.
That's the subcategory.
And then pass less authentication, you can click
or add method here.
And then you can
throw in a name, like, whatever. You can
say, whatever
suits your yeah. One password does does the
trick. Add new, and then you should be
prompted by your One password to actually
store
something.
Oh, yeah.
I guess you need to open password options
because one password needs to be configured properly
to
work with the browser of choice.
At least on on Mac OS,
there
it tries to store it on on the
iCloud keychain as it looks like. Oh, yeah.
It's trying to store on the iCloud keychain.
Yeah. But
pass keys, yeah, they work.
That's the short answer here.
I think it it took the iCloud thingy
right now. All it did What?
Yeah. Alright. Okay. Never mind.
Yeah. The UI,
one person and the iCloud key chain is
sometimes a little bit wanky.
I I do have it see, it's because
I I just I I change all my
stuff too much. Right? But I this is
the first day in, like, two years I've
run Firefox.
And whereas my one password to pass keys
is all configured properly on my normal browser.
So okay. I'll do that. I'll play with
that later.
Alright.
Very nice. I like this. It's very cool
system.
I mean, I don't wanna say it's painless
because it's it's identity. Right? It's it's not
painless. You've already endured the pain for us.
That that's the beauty of what Zitadel is
bringing to the table, and I love that.
I
mean, it's it's
really a comprehensive
thing, Zitadel. And
what we
we think Zitadel is best suited for is
if you're building a b to b case,
that's the strong suit of Zitadel. If you're
running b to c, that's where we can
work totally as well. It's not overly optimized
for workforce identity,
but because we like the the HR processes
and stuff. But from a technological standpoint, it
can do that as well.
So it's just our our focus definitely is
toward customer identity,
so to say. And that's where we try
to really, like, bring a turnkey solution
that does authentication for you. You can create
identities. You can
use external identity sources.
You can even use LDAP if you like.
I mean, if you go, like, for settings
here,
there is even, like,
an identity provider section on the left hand
side there.
A little upwards. Yes. And then you have,
like, a a lot of preconfigured providers here.
And there is also SAML if you wanna
give you the pain. You can do SAML
as well. And there is, like, a Active
Directory LDAP. You can also use that if
you wanna authenticate with preexisting
infrastructure.
It's more for for projects that are already
established rather than new.
Mhmm.
If you click on one of those, you
just get a whistle, basically. That's right. I
I will take action. Nothing plays will happen.
No. No. No.
I'm pretty sure if I click on one
of these, it's just it doesn't help spy
at all. Act LDAP active directory SAML. Those
are bad words in my book.
This is a bit of a a
random question. I know it's not that the
it's not, like, the directly the use case
result. You've covered what that is really well.
But, you know, there's a there is machine
to machine identity.
Right? This is something that's more prominent, and
I'm thinking of the use case of I
operate a number of Kubernetes clusters for my
Rawkode Academy infrastructure.
And, like, you know, if I can do
a generic YDC and I can hook that
up to the Kubernetes RBAC stuff, like, has
anyone explored this? Is this something that you've
you've played with yourself?
Yeah. We played around with Istio in the
past quite a lot, and and some of
our customers even use Istio.
But
we since then,
well, left the Kubernetes world for our infrastructure.
I mean, not in a bad mood, but
they'll try to to use, like, less operational
overhead for a start up. And, yeah, operationalizing
Kubernetes was kinda hard even though we did
run Kubernetes in the past quite a lot.
But we chose to use Cloud Run. I
have a whole talk about why switching from
Kubernetes to Cloud Run, but that's a different
thing.
Going from machine to machine stuff is kind
of what Zitadel can do as well. Let
me show you an example. If you go
for users in in in your UI,
And then you have, like, a toggle on
the lower a little bit on the left
there, you have a toggle, which is barely
visible, but we know that's that's a bad
design decision.
And then you can create service users. So
if we quickly create the service user,
just throw in whatever you wanna throw in
as as username.
Nothing
really bad can happen here.
Yes.
Just create it and and off we go.
Now you get basically
a a a service user, and users in
Zitadel are kind of the same. The only
thing they differ is the the the means
they have to authenticate
themselves.
And so in a service user, you can
basically choose to create personal access tokens. On
the left side, you can just create tokens
that can do whatever the service account can
do.
You can throw in an expiration date or
just create it unlimited,
and off you go.
Or you can create keys.
That's basically a pry a Jot private key
process.
Like, you get a Jot file from us,
like a private key, and you can use
that to sign your your payload, and then
we can give you a nice tidy token
back. We have a guide for that. So
and and our Go SDK can already take
care of it as well as the Terraform
library does all also the same.
But the reason being, you don't leak the
the your secret. Right? And that can be
used to basically build machine to machine processes
because
a machine user in Zitadel can have rights
in an application that is attached to Zitadel,
or it can have rights in Zitadel itself.
Like, for example, you build your your nice
register UI and you want to create your
users on your own, well, create a service
user,
call our API, and off you go.
Nice.
Very cool.
I'm gonna have to play with this a
bit more. It's got a nice little robot
icon.
I mean Yeah. There is there's also a
guide for that because
Alright. There's a follow-up in the chat
with regards to the b two b angle.
Sure.
So
it says thank you. Thank you for the
b two b case where the users don't
exist in Zitadel initially, but they use an
email domain to propagate them through to the
correct IDP.
Yep.
That's possible. You can attach the domain
to to an organization.
Like, you can say acme.com
belongs to the organization.
And as soon as the user arrives from
an IDP, like GitHub, for example, and the
email address ends with at acme dot com,
you can automatically register the user inside
that organization who owns the domain, basically.
Awesome.
I'm gonna jump back to our big face
mode. So I'll give everyone watching a little
bit of a warning. If you do have
any more questions, get them into the chat
quick.
Now I'm curious.
I don't wanna talk about the Kubernetes side.
Right? I think critical infrastructure, you know, needs
its own Kubernetes cluster. You should be running
it with your standard workloads,
which brings more complications. I
actually even though I operate many Kubernetes clusters,
I put critical stuff on, like, fly.io or
I run it on railway. Like or even
Cloud Run is another really good approach as
well. Yep.
It's like
yeah. I hadn't I didn't know Cloud Run
could do long running processes, though. That's not
something I've explored before. I thought it was
just serverless platforms, but I'm assuming
your Zitadel isn't spinning up as a cold
start every time, is it? Or
It's like usually one second ish
to to get ready and serve traffic.
Oh, Yeah.
If you look at the Docker Compose file
we opened,
there is an argument passed to Zitadel there,
which is start from init
that basically advises Zitadel, hey.
Start from from your init standpoint, like, okay.
Try to do all the migrations and figure
out whether everything is prep and ready and
and whether the projections are there and all
that stuff. But there is also a a
start flag. So you basically can tell Zitadel
just to start with whatever system is just
there, and that increases the start up cold
start times quite a lot. Like, you can
get one second call starts with that. That's
how we operate Zitadel on on Cloud Run
is basically
we have a a job that applies the
schema changes and stuff,
but the scaling containers, they just start
with the precondition of everything is already prepped
and ready. And the same
our Helm chart does the same.
You get, like, a job that does the
setup stuff and initialization,
but the serving containers will not start with
from scratch everything.
That's basically how you can separate and and
improve operational efficiency there.
Nice. I like that.
Alright. Let's finish on what's what's next. Right?
What are you and the team working on?
What's on your road map for the next
three or six months?
New shiny features are always a bonus, but,
of course,
share what you can.
I mean, there is also citadel.com/roadmap,
but I will give you the the the
yeah. There is it basically goes to a
GitHub
board. I mean, we are we are committed
to transparency.
That is one of our missions of really,
like, let's keep things transparent because we are
a security product. We wanna build trust in
what we do, and so we try to
keep as much
visible as feasible. Not not everything, but as
much as feasible.
And the the most important things we are
actually working on is
we are working on a an a an
already made login
that you can just fetch, and then you
basically get the Next. Js application you can
tailor to your needs, and it already brings
along the components you need, like input
fields and that things. So that's one thing
we are currently working on. There is also
there is already a a work in progress
prototype on Zitadel slash TypeScript.
One thing that will come is
user schemas is
what should be soon the the the work
should soon start.
The idea being we want to give our
users the the possibility to define how a
user should look like because
different needs across different ranges.
Right? Like, what is mandatory,
what's what's what's not mandatory, and all those
things, and we wanna give people the flexibility
to define it.
And, also, what will land
is an improved versions of our actions.
Actions basically is you can run a little
bit of JavaScript code, etcetera, at runtime
to alter things, like to call an HTTP
API to to fetch some data of your
CRM or whatnot. Or when a user registers,
you can do an HTTP post to your
application, such things.
And we are working on an improved version
there where you can
intercept HTTP requests. So you can basically
alter everything that Zitadel can give you from
an API perspective
and
also an event feed. So you can basically
tell Zitadel each
event that matches to x y z throws
something at me, and then I can react
on it. So you can do event driven
applications even further. Right? Like, if a user
logs in, we can send event. If a
user password verification fails, we can send an
event to you. You can do whatever you
want with it.
And so we wanna have, like, those features
really extended.
Main idea being you we give you an
SDK. You can run that in a cloud
flow or call, and you can handle what
we send you and do whatever you wanna
do with it. Right? Because we try to
to build the developer experience around the actions
thingy, like, with an embedded runtime.
But so far, the we thought, well, there
is cloud flow, course, there is they know
there is multiple other tools that can do
edge functions.
Why do we need
what's the need for us to do the
same? Let's just reuse what's are out there
and use the developer experience, basically. Because it's
easier to debug, right, if you have, like,
full ID support and everything, and you can
put pick your language of your choice and
yeah, let let's basically define an API. We
send you an HTTP request. We send you
an event, and off you go.
Nice. So extensibility,
basically, is the the main topic there that
will come.
Yeah. I like that.
Have you, anyone in your team, or any
tangential now? Right? But I'm just going there
because it popped into my head. Like,
I see a really compelling story for the
for the author and I know there's some
of the off c stuff, but, you know,
SpiceDB is written in Go, Zitadel is written
in Go. I could essentially just consume them
both as libraries, ship a single binary to
do off n and off c in a
very and they both speak Postgres.
Have you is that something you've ever explored
to, like,
do some interesting patterns there?
Actually, yes. We're always looking into to
what's the culmination or the perfect culmination of
identity? Like, you need our event capabilities. You
need user management. You need audit, and you
need authorization.
And
we think we should keep it open. That's
why we came up with the events design,
like sending events to other systems.
So if a user changes and say that
they'll let's send something to SpiceDB
or whatever tool you wanna use, there is
also permi permi permi
permi permi yeah. Yeah. Warrant's Warrant is also
out there. So let's let's give users the
choice and try to keep, like, an let
let's try to build kind of an ecosystem
to some extent.
Maybe at one point when we we grow
big enough, we will try to to to
bring something more mature along to the party
for people.
But until then, we we advise to do
that do it that way.
Nice.
Alright. Last question from the chat, and then
we'll wrap this up for today.
Have you had any thoughts or plans regarding
fine grained authorization?
It it per wraps perfectly. I mean,
yes, we have a lot of ideas about
it. We also thought of integrating it directly
into the call product.
Honestly speaking,
we we try to focus a little bit
more on on authentication and integration pieces of
Zitadel right now. But I said, maybe at
one point, we'll try to integrate something.
Until then, we we advise people to do
what it is best, and that is basically
use Zitadel for authentication
and, like, role based authorization
stuff Okay. Pass the info along
to your authorization engine of choice that can
be OPA, it can be Verint, it can
be SPICE DB.
Let let's let's try to use it that
way because they have invested quite a lot
of time of unbundling the fine grain authorization
stuff. Right? Mhmm.
It's also a topic a topic with a
huge depth to it. So that's
Yeah. A whole journey. The replies is basically
my question. Yeah. I wasn't sure if it
was a bit more specific or if it
was kinda, you know No. No. It it's
decode correct in the same direction.
Alright. That was awesome. It's such a good
product. It's open source. People can get started
today. There's a free tier on the cloud.
I mean, just go start kicking the tires
on it. This is a problem that, you
know, if your if your company wants to
make money, they have to deal with identity.
It's just there's no other way about it.
Yeah. And why burden your developers with stuff
that's already available open source right there to
you? So thank you so much to Florian
and to the entire Zitadel team. Again, amazing
product. Can't wait to start kicking the tires
on it myself.
Any final words that you wanna share with
people before we say goodbye?
We certainly like to have engagement on on
Discord, for example. So there is quite a
lot in active community over there. If if
people wanna hang out and ask questions about
Zitadel,
the best way to go is zitadel.com/chat.
That should send you to a discording web
page. Otherwise, feel free to engage with us
on GitHub as well
because if we really try to to build
the next great
framework or or turnkey solution that can really
bring you the value of not building authentication,
of not caring about past case implementation,
of of trying to avoid all those fallacies
and having basically a a well defined ready
made product for for the job. Right? And
so
enjoy the ride. Ask questions. There is a
lot of weird things you can tackle once
you wanna scale
such a system.
Like, you get a lot of operational headache,
and that's not especially due to Zitadel, but
that's just generally, identity is weird because you
deal with authenticated and not authenticated traffic.
And, yeah, give us a shout out if
you have interest or needs or questions.
We are an open minded community.
Alright. Well, I'm now in your Discord, so
I'll be throwing all my questions to your
team and the community as I explore.
But
thank you so much for your there. So
we'll see each other again. Oh, you I
know I know we could gonna be like,
I really hate that guy. Why is he
just keep asking so many questions?
No worries. No worries.
Alright. Thank you so much, It was wonderful
exposure project. Keep up the good work, and
hopefully, I'll see you again soon. And to
everyone who watched, have a wonderful day. Thanks.
Likewise. Thank you for having me.